when i was a little girl my mother took
me to see one of her favorite films
fellini's lestrada i was
a little young to read subtitles but
nonetheless she's an actor
and she wanted to share with me one of
the most extraordinary performances
that of julietta messina
her performance and that film
were filled with magic and heartbreak
and truth
and it was not the words but the
language of cinema
itself that transformed me forever
i also learned that lastrada was the
first
film to win the oscar in this next
category
here are the nominees for best
international
feature film from denmark another round
directed by thomas winterberg from hong
kong
better days directed by derek guo
from romania collective directed by
alexander nanao from tunisia
the man who sold his skin directed by
couture benjamina
from bosnia and herzegovina cuovarez
aida
directed by
[Music]
and the oscar goes to
another round denmark directed by thomas
winterberg
[Music]
wow
thank you very much thanks to the
academy
for voting on this film this is beyond
anything i could ever
imagine except this is something i've
always imagined
since i was five or something i've been
preparing speeches
in train stations at school
in the toilet and here i am it's real
it's amazing wow
this is a film about letting go of
control in life
and as i lost control in my own
and i want to thank my wife helene sits
over here
for being the angel of this project for
guiding me through this very
difficult period i want to thank my
children my family
nanaida albert lilly
my screenwriter tobias lynn holm
who's my guiding angel in both living
and writing
i'm sending you my praises
there's a lot of people to think but
i'll get i'll get there i'm sending my
praises to centropa caesar caspar
peter feeder cornum all of you
you had so much heart so much strength
at the same time
the crew who threw everything they had
in their hands to rescue me
and rescue this film
investors agents distributors
samuel goldwyn bart walker all of you
christina bastigas jessica sykes
bumble you're all there
cinetic thank you for showing the
bravery of investing in a movie that
is about four depraved
white drunk men basically who
teaches children to drink as well i mean
pretty uphills in my perspective uh
those four white men
being mounted milan las grande
thomas bolas my old friend the whole
cast you were brilliant
susan maria all of you took out your
hearts for this
and we're brilliant i want to send a
special thank of course to max mikkelsen
way best middleton yeah give him a hand
matt you gave us your finest
not just for the film but for my
daughter as well
and i'll never forget okay
so we wanted to make a film that
celebrates life
and um four days into shooting the
impossible happened
uh an accident on a highway took my
daughter away
someone looking into a cell phone
and we miss her and i love her
and
sorry uh
two months before we shot this movie and
two months before she died
she was in africa she sent me a letter
and she just read the script and she was
glowing with excitement
she loved this and she felt seen by this
and
uh she was supposed to be in this and
if anyone dares to believe that she's
here with us somehow
she you'll be able to see her clapping
clapping and cheering with us
we ended up making this movie for her as
her monument
so ida this is a miracle that just
happened
and you're part of this miracle
maybe you've been pulling some strings
somewhere i don't know but this one is
for you
thank you very much
you